[Música]
en primera plana
carlos serra
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
esto que ven en este objeto en los
celulares y como han sido la gran
revolución de nuestros tiempos como han
moldeado nuestros cerebros y cómo han
cambiado absolutamente nuestros tiempos
nos acompañan para hablar de la
revolución de los celulares en este
estudio israel ayala periodista
especializado en tecnología bienvenido
israel gracias por la invitación media
en el banco fundadora de la revista
feminista chic magazine bienvenida a
miriam hola victor hugo ramírez garcía
doctor en ciencias sociales por la
sorbona y profesor en sean o bienvenido
víctor hola qué tal la revolución
celular hoy en primera plana
en el año 2007 se toma como referencia
como el comienzo de la revolución en las
comunicaciones en este año ocurrieron
importantes eventos como el lanzamiento
del primer iphone por la compañía apple
y google a su vez lanza el sistema
operativo android casi han pasado 15
años y toca hacer balance porque
nuestras vidas han cambiado asistiendo a
lo que algunos llaman la mayor
revolución experimentada por el ser
humano
nuestro apéndice los celulares nos
acompañan a todas partes somos
dependientes de ellos para lo bueno y
para lo malo es difícil imaginar un
instrumento que haya cambiado tanto
nuestra forma de ser incluso moldeando
nuestras capacidades quizá la pregunta
sea cómo calibrar esta revolución que
promete incrementarse aún más con el
desarrollo de la 5g tecnología 5g
repasemos algunas portadas revista
alemana datum se pregunta en esta
portada si los smartphones han acabado
de arruinar una parte de nuestras vidas
ya difícil de recuperar el diario
católico la co alerta en esta otra
portada del peligro que suponen las
redes sociales para los adolescentes ya
no sólo por el tiempo de consumo también
por el fenómeno del acoso en redes la
revista filosofía se pregunta en esta
portada llegarán los celulares a ser
nuestros jefes a dominarnos bueno no sé
si esta pregunta es retórica pero
estamos sometidos a los celulares y esta
es la gran revolución humana de nuestro
tiempo es decir cómo calibrar
sometimiento y libertad en esta ecuación
israel yo pienso que la palabra clave es
el autocontrol
hay que saber un dato muy interesante es
que una persona en promedio pasa más de
seis horas viendo su smartphone
navegando en internet todo el día es un
cuarto del día y hay gente que incluso
más en la noche también se queda no
puede dormir porque no puede despegarse
de su celular no y los usos que le da la
gente es principalmente para encontrar
información estar en contacto con sus
amigos o para buscar productos no
entonces son cosas que son cotidianas
pero yo creo que la palabra clave es el
autocontrol saber cuándo es mucho y
saber cuándo hay que poner un alto no
hay también saber desconectarse quizás
es que nos cuesta no poder poner el
cursor no saber dónde está el cursor
miriam sometimiento a libertad es
difícil contestar a eso porque depende
claro de tu profesión yo que soy
periodista por ejemplo necesito a es
parte de mi trabajo y todo está muy
vinculado tu vida privada está muy
vinculada a tu vida profesional y cuando
me dicen eso contestó siempre es muy
difícil para mí cortar con el teléfono
porque es donde buscó información donde
intercambió información y creo que
depende de tu edad de tu provisión de si
vives solo o sola o no de dónde vives y
es muy difícil y por eso tenemos
adicciones porque hay hay cosas buenas
en los móviles en los móviles pero hay
cosas malas también creo que es la parte
del problema es que todo está vinculado
es muy difícil separar lo bueno de lo
humano
víctor
estamos atravesando todavía una de las
pandemias más fuertes que hayamos pasado
en la historia que hayamos registrado y
el uso de los móviles creo que fue vital
para muchos estar acompañando a nuestros
seres queridos desde los hospitales en
las cuarentenas entonces creo que hay
contrastes en el uso de los celulares
por ejemplo podríamos preguntarnos si
hubiera habido una primavera árabe sin
el uso de los celulares o si las
protestas de hong kong en 2020 hubieran
tenido la misma efectividad pero también
del otro lado por otra parte hay que
preguntarnos si los riesgos han
aumentado por ejemplo el robo de
identidad la venta de nuestros datos
personales entonces es muy complejo hay
un usuario complejo que analizar el año
2007 se tomaba como referencia lo decía
en la introducción con la explosión de
los smartphones que puntos destacarían
de lo ocurrido en este periodo de 15
años como evaluamos este período de 15
años israel efectivamente 2007 es un
periodo importante porque es cuando
comienza el lanzamiento del iphone un
año después empieza el comienza el
lanzamiento de los teléfonos android y a
partir de allí viene toda una serie
y desarrollos como por ejemplo
aplicaciones como whatsapp el
lanzamiento de la app store el
lanzamiento del android market son cosas
que usamos en nuestra vida cotidiana el
lanzamiento de messenger y es como un
cambio radical porque estamos vivo
acabamos de salir de una de un periodo
de pandemia en donde todo lo que nos
parecía imposible o lo que digamos
gobierno la digitalización de los
gobiernos el teletrabajo gracias a este
pequeño aparatito puede ser posible
puede ser posible tener conferencias vía
zoom estar conectados con nuestra
familia que no podíamos ver porque había
restricciones de viaje mismo las
aplicaciones ahora para entrar con un
pase sanitario en algunos países de
europa necesitas tener un celular sino
no puedes generar tu código qr y también
hay que entender que quien no tiene hoy
un celular puede tener varias
restricciones no es decir si tú no
tienes una y hay 9 por ciento de las
personas que tienen un celular que usan
un celular que no es un smartphone
quiere decir que estas personas utilizan
simplemente sm se utilizan cosas básicas
y que a lo mejor no van a poder realizar
ciertos aspectos
de su vida como por ejemplo trabajar
acceder a informaciones registrarse en
un sitio hoy para leer el menú en un
restaurante te piden y es a veces te
lleva sorpresas en algunos países donde
no algunos teléfonos no pueden leer un
código qr no puedes tener acceso al menú
osea digamos que ha invadido tantas
partes de nuestra vida cotidiana que hoy
es una herramienta extremadamente
importante y hay que saberla utilizar
con los beneficios que trae no lo que
está claro es que si dedicamos 6 horas
al día al smartphone hay capacidades
cerebrales del ser humano que se han ido
moldeando a ese uso de capacidades
humanas creen que ha cambiado para bien
y para mal los smartphones no sé cómo
como lo decíamos antes la capacidad de
concentrarse a claro ha bajado la
lectura a mí me gustaba mucho leer y
leemos mucho menos es verdad que la
concentración está claro que ha bajado
ha bajado porque siempre hay que
apagarlo pero actos continuos claro hay
siempre un bip siempre un mensaje
siempre algo pasando así que si quieres
cortar tienes que dejar el móvil en otra
habitación pero quien hace eso es muy
difícil es es lugar de la adicción que
queremos dejarlo pero no lo consigamos
hay gente más fuerte que otras en eso es
lo que deseas del autocontrol creo que
es un hay una injusticia porque hay hay
gente más fuertes que otras y dicen
mucho de tu
comportamiento adictivo hay gente más
adictas que otras y vale mucho para el
teléfono también bueno los psicólogos
sólo dicen que si tiene si tienes una
personalidad más adicta que otra vas a
caer mucho más en la dependencia y tú
sus facultades van a caer más eso que
otras capacidades
o perdedoras pueden ser la memoria no
necesitamos memorizar ahora números como
podían hacer nuestros padres o quizá la
orientación ahora con 'google maps' ya
nos manejamos cuando otras generaciones
anteriores nunca lo necesitaron víctor
como lo ve lo de las capacidades sí creo
que la pérdida de concentración es uno
de los síntomas más reveladores ahora
también desde que surgió la televisión
por ejemplo las generaciones acusaban de
que las generaciones más jóvenes perdían
concentración perdían retención es decir
hay que hacer como un estudio más
detallado sobre este estas nuevas
tecnologías que vienen desde desde desde
antes y lo que más me llama la atención
es el promedio de bala que a la que se
le da a un niño a una niña un celular en
el que ya se le otorga la capacidad de
tener todo este universo a la mano y que
en francia por ejemplo es de 10 años
alrededor y el desinterés de los padres
porque 7 de cada 10 padres y madres de
familia no saben lo que sus hijos y sus
hijas están haciendo están teniendo
acceso en redes
pero es tremendo porque sus compañeros
de clase tienen el smartphone como
privadas a tu hijo de tener lo que es un
poco y luego está la cuestión de
desintoxicarse cómo se desintoxica uno
de un smartphone es decir que qué
herramientas tenemos israel para saber
que tenemos una adicción exacto mira de
hecho es súper interesante porque la
adicción al teléfono se llama homofobia
es decir el miedo a no tener contigo el
celular no y algo más experimentado yo
creo todo es esa acción lo hemos
experimentado siempre todos en algún
momento exactamente cosas la adicción y
lo que genera esa ansiedad no entonces
primero hay que saber controlar esa
ansiedad al no tener el celular la otra
parte como lo podemos hacer pues
simplemente cuando no es necesario usar
el celular desactivas las notificaciones
lo puedes poner en el modo avión pero al
final de cuentas es una decisión
personal y hay que tener mucho control
mental de saber decir cuando sí lo puedo
usar en qué situaciones cuando ya es
demasiado y si lo requiere usar
ya sea por medios profes para medios
profesionales ok pero si ya estoy
pasando a por ejemplo un fenómeno que se
llama el boom ping que es conectarte
hasta las altas horas de la noche seguir
con tu teléfono y no poder dormir en ese
caso pues ya representa una señal de
alarma pues porque ya es demasiado
tiempo y también hay una u otro fenómeno
que se llama como falling que es cuando
el otro no te responde a un mensaje que
le has enviado y te envías a dar
ansiedad no entonces genera todo este
tipo de grandes transtornos tremendos
que finalmente yo creo que se digamos se
detienen con mucho autocontrol mucho
saber cuando sí cuando no hay mucho
control mental claro pero no se nos da
toda esta tecnología y se nos habla de
autocontrol pero por otra parte lo que
tendremos que pensar es que se necesita
educación no porque como decía miriam
antes es también muy injusto no para que
se nos entregue tanta tecnología que
muchas veces depende de nuestra
capacidad para no tener una adicción a
ella la educación tiene que formar parte
de esta ecuación del autocontrol hay
gente que no pueden hacer eso yo leía
historias de digital detox que se pone
muy de moda porque hay gente que no
consigue hacer eso así que la única
forma que tienen para
desintoxicarse es dejar el móvil durante
una semana y leía algo de una bloguera
las blogueras son muy dependientes y
decía que no se daba cuenta de todo lo
que podía hacer sin teléfono no es solo
no contestar a un mensaje pero es tener
el espacio mental para pintar su
departamento que él no lo hacía no sé
leer un libro por ejemplo pero también
estar el ejemplo que era muy interesante
que daba estar en un restaurante con
amigos sin el móvil en la mesa sin tomar
fotos de lo que comes y eso no es una
sola foto un solo mensaje y tal pero más
si sumamos todo es mucho tiempo donde no
estamos de verdad con la otra persona
eso del vínculo social es muy
interesante porque te permite tener más
vínculos con gente con esto que decía
pero a veces estás sin estar y muchas
veces estar sin está así que la la de
textura es un poco extrema pero creo que
funciona nunca lo he probado me da mucho
miedo probarlo no estoy lista a lo mejor
lo tenemos que empezar a pensar todos a
hacerlo de la digital detox vamos a
hacer en este punto una breve pausa y
enseguida volvemos aquí en primera plana
para hablar de esta revolución de los
celulares hasta ahora
[Música]
cada 30 minutos france24 les ofrece una
actualización de los acontecimientos más
importantes de américa latina y el
número últimas noticias contexto y
análisis todo lo que necesita saber para
estar bien informado
noticias en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellos hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
soy natalia mendoza su corresponsal de
france 24 en roma' sigan conmigo todas
las noticias de italia en nuestros
noticieros y en la programación diaria
natalia mendoza una de los 200
corresponsales de france 24 en el mundo
seguimos aquí en primera plana de radio
francia internacional y de france 24
esta semana hablando de esto de los
celulares y de la revolución de las
celulares de lo que supone para nosotros
como una especie de apéndice humano lo
hacemos con israel ayala periodista
especializado en tecnologías miriam le
banco fundadora de la revista feminista
chic magazine y víctor hugo ramírez
sociólogo de todos los aspectos que
incorpora un celular víctor cual
consideran más revolucionario las redes
sociales por ejemplo que han modificado
completamente nuestra forma de
socializarnos si hay plataformas y
tecnologías hay redes sociales pero
también las prácticas por ejemplo el
sexting hablábamos de el sexting es por
ejemplo el intercambio de contenidos de
todo tipo visuales audiovisuales
de contenido de tipo erótico sexual
entre usuarios y hablábamos de si hacía
falta educación sobre sobre el uso de
tecnologías y hace falta educación sobre
estas nuevas prácticas que se empiezan
desde nuestros adolescentes de las
nuevas generaciones no quienes han
intentado un poco que ministerios de
educación ha intentado meter políticas
de ciberseguridad y desde sexto está por
ejemplo australia reino unido en
montreal y algunos lugares en eeuu cuál
ha sido la reacción padres y madres que
dicen no podemos tratar estos temas
todavía porque nuestros niños y niñas
son todavía muy jóvenes cuando en
realidad le estamos dando un celular a
un niño a una niña de 10 años entonces
hay estos problemas de las políticas
educativas que necesitamos hacer frente
desde ya dirían que somos más
información al mente competentes gracias
a los smartphones más capaces de
encontrar un dato rápidamente pero mucho
más incapaces de retener ese mismo dato
que hemos ido a buscar yo creo que sí
porque bueno tienes la facilidad de
tener ya
internet o cualquier cosa que tú quieres
buscar lo haces a través de google
quieres saber dónde se encuentra un
restaurante lo haces a través de
internet quieres tener un review de un
producto lo haces también a través de tu
smartphone quieres encontrar no sea
nuevas personas de hecho 29% de las
personas que tienen un smartphone lo
usan para encontrar pareja es un dato
súper interesante que salió entonces si
es mucho más fácil obtener información
pero también mucho más fácil olvidar
cierto tipo de cosas no sé hoy no puedes
saber cuáles son los 10 números de
teléfono de tus mejores amigos hoy si
buscas una calle a lo mejor al día
siguiente se te olvida dónde está el
mismo para llegar a ese lugar hay
aplicaciones que ya te permiten hacerlo
la gente lo sigue y el día de mañana
pues ya no te acuerdas que línea hay que
tomar o qué línea de metro que autobús
entonces si es mucho más fácil olvidar y
nos queda una memoria que yo diría de
teflón
ahora va a víctor del sexting lo
nombraba antes también miriam el tema de
la educación quizá el punto sea si creen
que la educación en nuevas tecnologías
es suficiente la que se está dando ahora
mismo en las escuelas si no se hace
tiempo que no voy a la escuela y me
pregunto cómo están educados los jóvenes
es lo que decías hay que tener educación
en todos los temas y no sé cómo va a ser
cómo va a ser esa generación que ahora
tiene diez y diez o quince años cómo van
a descubrir la vida eso del sexting si
empiezas tu vida sexual así como saber
lo que se hacen lo que no se hace y
también para desarrollar vínculos
sociales en la escuela hay tantas cosas
que aprendes y ya no sé cómo van a
crecer rezagaron después modificadas
claro que nosotros lo hemos descubierto
en camino pero si empiezas tu vida
social así y lo de la información
también hay que tener una educación
fuerte porque podemos encontrar mucha
información pero también mucha fe que
'news y sabemos que los de los
algoritmos hay muchas noticias que ni
y sabes lo que te llegas es lo que
habíamos buscado antes así que tenemos
una forma una vista del mundo mucho más
reducida es como una biblioteca si no
sabes dónde buscar no buscas
al hablando de la educación nombrada
antes víctor la educación de padres que
no saben cómo utilizan esos niños del
smartphone pero a pesar de ello la
escuela debe garantizar una educación en
este tipo de tecnologías pese a que tus
padres no conozcan los sean ignorantes
respecto a evidentemente yo que me
dedico a políticas educativas siempre
tengo la oportunidad de estar en
contacto con padres y madres de familia
que se preocupan por lo que los nuevos
las nuevas tecnologías los celulares el
internet trae hacia hacia sus hijos y
creo que no hay que adoptar porque hay
padres y madres que dicen no hay que
prohibir a las nuevas prácticas hay que
prohibir el sexo y decirle a nuestros
hijos no hay que no intercambios fotos
etcétera
del lado libertario dirían es mi
libertad si yo intercambio fotos de
contenido íntimo erótico sexual con
quien yo quiera etcétera lo que hay que
hacer es
y políticas educativas que orienten a
las nuevas generaciones sobre los
riesgos que tienen las nuevas prácticas
porque hay prácticas que llegaron para
quedarse que ya son ya forman parte
nuestra cotidianidad protocolos también
de seguridad protocolos de ciberacoso 1
de cada 5 niños y niñas en francia ha
sido víctima de ciberacoso entonces creo
que son cifras que nos digan que llevar
a tomar cartas en el asunto y a diseñar
políticas educativas concretas en estos
temas y desde luego son cifras que
interpelan como también lo hace esa
nueva tanda de documentos filtrados de
facebook que reafirman la obsesión de la
compañía por atraer a usuarios
adolescentes a instagram a pesar de los
estudios internos de la compañía que
revelaron que la presión por la
perfección y el algoritmo de la red
social producen un efecto tóxico en
muchos de ellos en israel antes de
hablar de ello me gustaría preguntarte
cómo funciona esta guerra por los
adolescentes entre las grandes redes
sociales entre facebook y la china tick
tock es una verdadera batalla de
marketing por los adolescentes a lo que
estamos asistiendo yo creo que más que
una batalla de marketing es una por el
big data la información todo que estás
conectado con quien te conectas hay toda
una mina de oro escondida en la en la
metadata que obtienen estas estas
aplicaciones sobre todo en dictó que es
la que más peligro yo diría es la más
peligrosa porque pues ahora en eeuu
acaban de aceptar que dictó puede
recabar datos biométricos tus huellas
digitales el reconocimiento facial que
usó se le va a dar a eso y sobre todo
porque hay una cantidad de personas
menores de edad que son las que más
utilizan este tipo de redes sociales
tipo facebook no tanto porque el público
de facebook es la gente de más de 65
años es el grueso de la digamos que es
un poco la reliquia que quedó pero aún
así hay adolescentes que utilizan
instagram que también forma parte del
grupo facebook y lo que pasó con
instagram es que te crea una falsa
imagen de la persona o sea la persona a
través de los filtros la en una vida que
no existe una vida
creada entonces una superficialidad y
justamente hablando de la parte que toca
del acoso hacia hacia los niños por
ejemplo en tick tock hay tendencias
últimamente una hubo una que se llamaba
anti 2010 que iba en contra de los niños
nacidos en el 2010 y los acosaban en la
escuela les decían que eran unos
malnacidos por haber naciones e-mails y
todo venía por una tendencia que se creó
en tick tock entonces hasta ese a este
hasta ese punto puede llegar la
viralidad de ciertos contenidos es
alucinante de verdad bueno claro es el
peligro de la vida a través de filtros
que es lo que nos muestra instagram que
es algo muy peligroso acá para
adolescentes incluso habría había
estudios internos que y sobre todo para
para mujeres que sabemos que son más
víctimas de la presión de los dictados
de la belleza física y instagram tiene
muchos muchos problemas por eso porque
instagram dice creo que 30 por ciento de
los adolescentes mujeres dicen que se
pueden depresiva
por causa de instagram porque hay
demasiada presión de la imagen perfecta
de eso de los filtros y lo que inter lo
que es interesante y yo quería hacer
búsquedas sobre eso es el fenómeno de
las cirugías de tics
en los jóvenes se ponen más y más
importantes por causa de los filtros
porque las mujeres quieren conseguir
este cuerpo con talla muy final con
donde de las nalgas no sé hay cuatro hay
nuevos cuerpos por instagram que se
están creando y la vida de las mujeres
jóvenes quieren ser este cuerpo y cree
en la seguridad estética es un fenómeno
muy fuerte ahora y no nos damos cuento
en parís a nuestra edad que hay que
tener mucho cuidado en eso y en américa
latina creo que es muy fuerte y el
francia como tenemos este mito de la
belleza natural y todos no nos damos
cuenta de que está subiendo mucho por
los filtros y víctor
suena el doble estándar del de instagram
y de facebook sobre mostrar los pechos
de
prohibirla y mostrar los pechos mujeres
cuando en realidad de los de los hombres
está perfecto además también hay que
separar las tecnologías de los
paradigmas culturales porque por ejemplo
no vamos a culpar a los automóviles de
los accidentes automovilistas es decir
vivimos los paradigmas estéticos los
vivimos dentro de las redes dentro las
tecnologías y fuera los anuncios estamos
inundados en las en el metro en la vía
pública de estos modelos de perfección
de belleza estética que son obviamente
sexistas patriarcales y en muchas veces
racistas también ya todo esto se le suma
ahora la tecnología 5g israel que
promete aún más velocidad y más
revolución explicarnos en qué consiste y
cómo va a cambiar nuestra vida la 5g
pues las 5 que ya viene desarrollándose
desde años atrás y es el next step hacia
la que viene después de la tecnología 44
g qué quiere decir esto que en el futuro
vamos a tener más realidad virtual más
real aumentada el internet el desarrollo
del internet de las cosas es decir
varios objetos conectados al mismo
tiempo estaba leyendo que es una
tecnología que es muchísimo es mil veces
más rápida vamos a poder tener 20
gigabytes por segundo y qué quiere decir
eso que por ejemplo el día de mañana
vamos a poder tener cirugías realizadas
a distancia a través de un robot por
ejemplo vamos a tener autos autónomos
conectados manejando sin conductor vamos
a tener estados del tráfico en tiempo
real en varias ciudades para tomar
decisiones y es una tecnología que
básicamente fue creada para las empresas
no para el usuario sino también para los
gobiernos no es decir cómo manejar
sistemas complejos a través de una
tecnología que llegue al usuario y poder
tomar decisiones al instante no me
imagino que lo del día de mañana es
literalmente mañana
en algunos países está muy desarrollado
comienza a implantarse hay 60 países en
donde ya tienen tecnologías 5 en américa
latina
hay desarrollos en ciertas ciudades en
méxico el desarrollo digamos moderado
empezará a partir de 2022 en otros
países de américa latina como argentina
en 2023 así que hay una disparidad
porque también es una tecnología costosa
la penetración todavía no es alta y hay
que hacer muchísimos tests bueno a modo
de conclusión con lo que no está
contando israel no sé si creen que los
smartphones están determinando muchos de
nuestros comportamientos y todavía lo
van a hacer más a futuro nuestra forma
de pensar de informarnos incluso de
votar víctor sí claro que sí los cambios
está ahí son cambios culturales son
cambios de adaptación de nuevas
generaciones en las tecnologías y con
las 5 que también creo que va a ser todo
un tema de lo que me llama la atención
es el tema de compatibilidad es decir
vamos a tener que cambiar nuestros
aparatos para que sean compatibles va a
haber una ola de consumo que va a hacer
que cambiemos nuestros bars o peor
nuestros y que además tiene efectos de
emisión de carbono es decir la
manufactura de los celulares tiene
efectos de emisión de carbono sobre
nuestros nuestros problemas de cambio
climático pues aquí lo dejamos no tengo
tiempo para más pero sí un placer miriam
víctor israel compartir con ustedes esta
edición de en primera plana en la que
hemos hablado de la gran revolución de
los celulares de todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana en primera plana gracias